Welcome to SmartList, uh, it's, uh, is what we normally would say when we do an opening, but today is different because today is welcome to SmartList. Well, that's what I just said. Pretty close. Smart. Right. Smart. Right.
欢迎来到SmartList，呃，这，呃，是我们开场时通常会说的话，但今天不同，因为今天是欢迎来到SmartList。好吧，我刚才就是这么说的。差不多。Smart。对。Smart。对。
Smart. Right. Smart. Right. Smart. Right. We have a mute button for my laughter because Jason, you got me rolling. Yeah.
Smart。对。Smart。对。Smart。对。我们有个静音按钮可以消掉我的笑声，因为杰森，你让我笑得前仰后合。是的。
If you just pull up the sleeves there, you can look like, uh, Danny Terrio. Look at that. Wait, what was it? What was the name of, um, John Travolta's character in Greece? Danny. Danny Zuko. Danny Zuko, dude. Danny Zuko.
如果你把袖子卷起来，看起来就像，呃，丹尼·泰里奥。看看那个。等等，那是什么？约翰·特拉沃尔塔在《油脂》里的角色叫什么名字？丹尼。丹尼·祖科。丹尼·祖科，伙计。丹尼·祖科。
was the host of, not Dance Nation. No, it was dance party. Dance fever. Dance fever. Dance fever, good. Yeah, my 14 year old is drinking coffee, has done for the last, I don't know, six months or so. Very grown up thing.
是那个节目的主持人，不是《舞蹈国度》。不，是《舞蹈派对》。《舞蹈狂热》。《舞蹈狂热》。《舞蹈狂热》，很好。是的，我14岁的孩子在喝咖啡，过去六个月左右一直都在喝。非常成熟的表现。
Yeah. I was surprised by what sort of a reflex I had to her drinking coffee. I thought, well, wait a second, that's just, she's too young for that. Like I was reacting like she was like, she poured herself a couple of fingers of scotch, you know, neat.
是的。我对她喝咖啡的反应之大感到惊讶。我想，等等，这不对，她太小了，不能喝那个。我的反应就像她给自己倒了几盎司苏格兰威士忌，你知道，纯饮一样。
Why, why? Because it's too early. Yeah. No, yeah, I feel like kids aren't supposed to drink coffee until they're not kids, till they're 18. You know what though, Archie's been doing it at, Archie's 12 and he's drinking coffee. Truly?
为什么，为什么？因为太早了。是的。不，是的，我觉得孩子们在长大之前，也就是18岁之前，不应该喝咖啡。不过你知道吗，阿奇一直在喝，阿奇才12岁，他就在喝咖啡。真的吗？
Yeah. But for girls, I think it's those Olsen twins that they were always photographed with a Starbucks coffee. So the young girls probably thought, that's cool, I want to be like the Olsen twins. You want to hang this on the Olsen twins? Yeah.
是的。但对于女孩来说，我想是因为奥尔森双胞胎总是被拍到拿着星巴克咖啡。所以年轻女孩可能觉得，那很酷，我想变得像奥尔森双胞胎一样。你想把这归咎于奥尔森双胞胎？是的。
Yeah, but you know, the old wives tale that it stunts your growth and, you know, God bless them both, they're not tall, right? So, okay, and we'll be right back with the word from our sponsors. Jason, can I talk to you for a minute? No, but listen, there, I love them. And I think they're adorable and sweet and normal.
是的，但你知道，那个老掉牙的说法是它会阻碍生长，而且，上帝保佑她们俩，她们长得不高，对吧？所以，好的，我们稍后回来，听听赞助商的话。杰森，我能跟你说句话吗？不，但是听着，我爱她们。而且我觉得她们很可爱、甜美且正常。
Believe me, they're not bummed out about that their average height, they're doing okay. Wait, Jason, now you're taking a swig of your coffee. That's right. Well, I'm tall enough. From Starbucks. I'm tall enough, I'm fine. I did stop, I did.
相信我，她们不会因为自己平均身高而感到沮丧，她们过得很好。等等，杰森，你现在正在喝你的咖啡。没错。好吧，我够高了。来自星巴克。我够高了，我很好。我确实停了，我确实停了。
How tall are you? Well, that was my point, I'm 5'11". And until maybe five years ago, I just kind of rounded up to six foot. And I just, I hit, I hit F it. I'm all about being overly honest. Now I'm 5'11", damn it. You remember what I did to my friend Eli,
你多高？好吧，这就是我的重点，我5英尺11英寸。直到大约五年前，我一直四舍五入说是6英尺。然后我，我放弃了。我主打一个过度诚实。现在我是5英尺11英寸，该死。你记得我对我的朋友伊莱做了什么吗，
who I was working with? I told you about that. I think I told both of you guys that Eli kept saying he was six feet and I don't wanna call him out. Sorry, I'll take his name out. My friend. No, we're gonna call everybody out in this. That's way too loud.
那个和我一起工作的人？我跟你说过那个。我想我告诉过你们俩，伊莱一直说他有6英尺，我不想拆穿他。抱歉，我会隐去他的名字。我的朋友。不，我们要在这儿拆穿所有人。那声音太大了。
And then he said, and he said he was six feet. And finally one day I was like, dude, you're not six feet and he was like, yes I am. So we got- He's not even 5'11", right? So we got a measuring, and it's like, you gotta take your shoes off. He's like, oh fuck, I gotta take my shoes off.
然后他说，他说他有6英尺。最后有一天我说，伙计，你没有6英尺，他说，我确实有。所以我们拿了——他甚至不到5英尺11英寸，对吧？所以我们拿了测量工具，他说，你得把鞋脱了。他说，哦该死，我得把鞋脱了。
And then I said, and your hat. Yeah, and your stilt. And comb your hair. Yeah, bring your hair down to your scalp. So yeah, 5'11". And I said, it's okay, you don't need to be, not everybody- How tall are you, Will?
然后我说，还有你的帽子。是的，还有你的高跷。还有梳理你的头发。是的，把头发压到头皮上。所以是的，5英尺11英寸。我说，没关系，你不需要，不是每个人——你多高，威尔？
How tall are you? I'm like pushing 6'3". No, yeah, well that means you're 6'2". God, we just had the conversation. I'm saying I'm 6'2". Yeah, we literally just talked about not lying. I'm not lying. What about you, Sean?
你多高？我大概接近6英尺3英寸。不，是的，好吧，那意味着你是6英尺2英寸。天哪，我们刚才还在讨论这个。我说我是6英尺2英寸。是的，我们刚才还在谈论不要撒谎。我没撒谎。你呢，肖恩？
I'm 6". No, I'm 5'11". Yeah. But wait a minute, how do you- Wait, mystery guest, you got to hush, mystery guest. Wait, we have a mystery guest. God, all right, you know what, here, let's just bring her on now.
我是6英尺。不，我是5英尺11英寸。是的。但等等，你怎么——等等，神秘嘉宾，你得安静点，神秘嘉宾。等等，我们有一位神秘嘉宾。天哪，好吧，你知道吗，来，我们现在就把她请出来吧。
She's eager to talk, clearly. Yep. Folks, today we have joining us the standard bearer for all who look to be successful, man or woman, at being a professional, a parent, a partner, a friend, an adult child, a leader, an inspiration, a role model, an icon, and a mogul, okay? She has more beauty, humor, and warmth
她显然很想说话。是的。各位，今天加入我们的是所有追求成功的人的标杆，无论男女，无论是作为专业人士、父母、伴侣、朋友、成年子女、领导者、灵感来源、榜样、偶像还是大亨，好吗？她拥有比一个人三辈子都用不完的
than one person can use in three lifetimes. She's also got an Oscar, an Emmy, a Golden Globe, a SAG. She's got two teenagers, a smoking husband, a dozen cats, eight pandas, and she speaks every language currently known. But all these things together may not be bigger than her lifestyle company that rhymes with soup, friends, it's Gwyneth Paltrow.
美貌、幽默和温暖。她还有奥斯卡奖、艾美奖、金球奖、演员工会奖。她有两个十几岁的孩子，一个帅气的丈夫，十几只猫，八只熊猫，而且她会说目前已知的所有语言。但所有这些加起来可能都没有她那个名字押韵“汤”的生活方式公司大，朋友们，她是格温妮丝·帕特洛。
It's Goop. No. Yeah. It's Gwyneth. Hi. Hi, guys. I'm sorry, I thought I was on mute. Look at how adorable, even with headphones on,
是Goop。不。是的。是格温妮丝。嗨。嗨，伙计们。抱歉，我以为我静音了。看看多可爱，即使戴着耳机，
you're the cutest thing in the world. Ever. And of course, they're fancy headphones. Very nice of you to join us. I want to jump right off to the thing, you know, I do a lot of deep research on- You look like you're reading of a prompter. Well, yeah, this is Wikipedia cut and pasted.
你也是世界上最可爱的人。一直都是。当然，那是高级耳机。很高兴你能加入我们。我想直接切入正题，你知道，我做了很多深入的研究——你看上去像是在读提词器。好吧，是的，这是从维基百科上剪切粘贴的。
What about studying anthropology at the University of California? What, that sounds- That's actually not true. Come on, Wikipedia doesn't lie. I studied art history at UC Santa Barbara, amongst other things, but then I dropped out. Never anthropology.
关于在加州大学学习人类学呢？什么，那听起来——那其实不是真的。得了吧，维基百科不会撒谎。我在加州大学圣塔芭芭拉分校学习艺术史，还有其他一些东西，但后来我退学了。从来没学过人类学。
No, but I just loved it. I liked, you know, Margaret Mead and I still do. And my mom was, I always said to her, I want to be an actress like you. And she said, oh, don't, you're way too smart. Be an anthropologist. Well, now really quick, your mom, for my sister in Wisconsin-
不，但我只是喜欢它。我喜欢，你知道，玛格丽特·米德，我现在依然喜欢。我妈妈是，我总是对她说，我想成为像你一样的演员。她说，哦，别，你太聪明了。去当人类学家吧。好吧，现在很快问一下，你妈妈，为了我在威斯康星州的姐姐——
Blithe Danner. Is Blithe Danner. Blithe Danner. Who was actually played Will's mom on the program, Will and Grace. And so I've known your mom for a long time and she's one of the greatest actresses, one of the nicest, sweetest people
布莱丝·丹纳。是布莱丝·丹纳。布莱丝·丹纳。她在《威尔和格蕾丝》节目中饰演威尔的妈妈。所以我认识你妈妈很久了，她是地球上最伟大的演员之一，也是最善良、最甜美的人之一，
you'll ever meet on the planet. I love her. I worked with her too, I can vouch for that. I did too, she played Christina's mom on up all night, remember, Sean? Oh yeah, that's right. Yeah, so we've all worked with your mom and we- She gets around.
你永远会遇到的。我爱她。我也和她合作过，我可以担保。我也合作过，她在《整夜难眠》里演克里斯蒂娜的妈妈，记得吗，肖恩？哦，是的，没错。是的，所以我们都和你妈妈合作过，我们——她到处都是。
Let's just get it out of the way. We love your mom. You've worked with your mom, yes, yeah. Yes, I came out of her vagina and I've worked with her multiple times. This is a family show. So I can also vouch for her. Oh, God, what about when she said
让我们直接说出来吧。我们爱你妈妈。你和你妈妈合作过，是的，是的。是的，我从她的阴道里出来，我和她合作过好几次。这是一个家庭节目。所以我也可以为她担保。哦，天哪，当她说
you're too smart to be an actress? What, I haven't heard that before. I've heard like, oh, it's not a meritocracy and it's all a bunch of fakes and phonies. But that- You've heard that when people were talking to you, you've heard that? Yeah, but to jump on that, Jason,
你太聪明了，不适合当演员时，那是怎么回事？什么，我以前没听过这个。我听过的是，哦，这不是精英管理，这都是一群骗子和虚伪的人。但那个——你听到过别人对你说过这个吗？是的，但要接着说，杰森，
because being the only one here out of the bunch of us today who don't have children and forgets along the lines of where Jason is going, why do parents in show business always try to discourage their children entering the same business in which they dreamed of being a part of? It is amazing.
因为作为今天我们这群人中唯一没有孩子的人，而且忘记了杰森要说的方向，为什么演艺圈的父母总是试图劝阻他们的孩子进入他们梦想参与的同一个行业？这太神奇了。
Why is that? I think because it's tough. I mean, it's very, very difficult to succeed. And I think most days it can be very demoralizing. And I think as parents, right, you fundamentally want to protect your children from pain and disappointment. And you know firsthand how hard it can be
为什么会这样？我想是因为这很艰难。我的意思是，成功非常、非常困难。而且我认为大多数时候这会让人非常沮丧。而且我认为作为父母，对吧，你从根本上想要保护你的孩子免受痛苦和失望。而且你知道第一手资料，这有多难，
and we're successful. So, or I used to be before I quit. You're doing okay. You're doing alright. Wait, you quit? Let's get into that. I mean, you know. She has stepped back.
而且我们很成功。所以，或者我以前是，在我辞职之前。你做得很好。你做得不错。等等，你辞职了？让我们深入探讨一下。我的意思是，你知道。她已经退居幕后了。
More or less. I haven't fully quit, but it's been a while. You've been busy with your very successful business that goes by the name Goop, which has been incredibly successful. And I know my friend John Alexander was a painter and lives in New York and he has his studios in Amagansett and you guys had one of your first shops
或多或少吧。我没有完全退出，但已经有一段时间了。你一直忙于你非常成功的公司，名字叫Goop，它非常成功。我知道我的朋友约翰·亚历山大是一位画家，住在纽约，他在阿马甘塞特有工作室，你们的第一批商店之一
was like on his driveway there. And I remember at first he was like, ah, the Goopies, they're in here. They've taken over my driveway. I don't know. He was just like all the young people who worked there. And then within like two weeks, he's like, these people are great.
就在他那里的车道上。我记得起初他是说，啊，那些Goop的人，她们在这儿。她们占领了我的车道。我不知道。他只是觉得所有在那里工作的年轻人。然后两周内，他就说，这些人太棒了。
I love them and they bring me coffee and you know. Now, a lot of people will call you, those who are invited to be your friend and know you well will call you GP. And that is where, correct me if I'm wrong, the name came from. It's GP, but in the middle there are two O's because somebody told you early on
我爱她们，她们给我带咖啡，你知道。现在，很多人会叫你，那些被邀请成为你朋友并了解你的人会叫你GP。这就是，如果我错了请纠正我，名字的由来。是GP，但在中间有两个O，因为有人很早就告诉你
that successful online companies have two O's in them. Is that correct? This is a true story. Is that true? That's amazing, is that great? I was trying to figure out what to call it. I didn't want my name in it and I wanted it to sort of maybe be a made up word
成功的在线公司名字里都有两个O。这是正确的吗？这是一个真实的故事。是真的吗？太神奇了，那很棒吗？我当时在想该叫它什么。我不想把我的名字放进去，我想让它听起来像是一个编造的词，
or something that was short. And I was consulting with an old friend of mine named Peter Arnell who was like a marketing and advertising genius in New York. And he was trying to help me and he was just like, I got it, it's Goop. And I was like, that's terrible. I mean, it's not, I think the original connotation
或者是一个简短的词。我当时在咨询我的一位老朋友，名叫彼得·阿内尔，他是纽约的市场营销和广告天才。他当时在试图帮助我，他只是说，我搞定了，叫Goop。我说，那太糟糕了。我的意思是，不是，我认为最初的内涵
was probably not that delicious sounding Goop. How long are we gonna have to wait for Jube, Jason? When is Jube coming? We're working on that. He's launching our men's. Yeah, is it men's lifestyle? Yeah, well, it's, let's go, we're making news, Gwyneth. Let's announce it now.
可能不是那个听起来很美味的Goop。我们要等Jube多久，杰森？Jube什么时候来？我们正在努力。他正在推出我们的男装。是的，是男士生活方式吗？是的，好吧，我们要发布新闻了，格温妮丝。我们现在宣布吧。
Wells would be, whoa. Whoa, whoa. Speaking of Vajana, as I said to my, I was dropping my son off at school on the West Side today and I said, we were in the car and I go, stop at the stoplight. I wanted to see his reaction. I go, so, hey, we just got this time here.
威尔会，哇。哇，哇。说到阴道，正如我对我儿子说的，我今天送我儿子去西区的学校，我说，我们在车里，我说，在红绿灯处停下。我想看看他的反应。我说，那么，嘿，我们现在有时间。
You and me in the car. I said, I guess it's time, he's 10. We talk about the birds and the bees and the looks. I just want to see, and he just goes like this, no. It was a look of disgust, listener. He's like, dad, I learned it all on Pornhub. He's like, I know everything. He's like, please don't say anything right now.
你和我在一起。我说，我想是时候了，他10岁了。我们谈谈关于鸟类和蜜蜂以及外表。我只是想看看，他只是这样，不。那是一种厌恶的表情，听众们。他说，爸爸，我全在Pornhub上学到了。他说，我知道一切。他说，请现在什么都别说。
Please don't say anything more. I know how heard it. I was like, okay, all right. Wait, you didn't drill down on that, pun intended. You didn't say, hey, tell me what you know. Tell me how you think it happens. He turns out he knows, but I was just gonna say, no, it made me think when you said
请别再说什么了。我知道怎么听到的。我说，好吧，好吧。等等，你没有深究那个，双关语。你没有说，嘿，告诉我你知道什么。告诉我你是怎么认为它发生的。结果他知道，但我只是想说，不，当你提到
that you came out of your mom's vagina. It just made me think I was having this conversation. I didn't get to that, but I was just having a conversation with one of my children this morning about it. Gwyneth, do you remember your conversation with both your kids, with Apple and Moses, about birds and the bees?
你从你妈妈的阴道里出来时，这让我想到我正在进行这个对话。我没说到那一步，但我今天早上确实和我的一个孩子谈过这个。格温妮丝，你还记得你和你的两个孩子，苹果和摩西，关于鸟类和蜜蜂的谈话吗？
Did you ever have it? You know. I haven't done it yet with a 14 year old. So at their elementary school here in Los Angeles where they went, they gave them the most a comprehensive sex ed class in the sixth grade that they came home, sixth grade, they came home, and they had been taught everything.
你谈过吗？你知道。我还没和14岁的孩子谈过。所以他们在洛杉矶的小学，他们去的那里，他们在六年级给了他们最全面的性教育课，他们回家了，六年级，他们回家了，他们被教了一切。
And when I say everything, I mean everything. It was wild. Our guide kids go to the same school or went. Did you feel that it was too early, too late, or right on time? I thought it was perfect. What's that, 12 years old, sixth grade? Yeah, yeah.
当我说是“一切”时，我是指一切。太疯狂了。我们的向导孩子去的是同一所学校或者去过。你觉得太早了，太晚了，还是正合适？我觉得很完美。那是多少，12岁，六年级？是的，是的。
Yeah, that's right. That's pretty right. Well, how did you know that like, did you have them download you on what they? I mean, my daughter came home with her best friend, Emily, and she was like, they were stunned. And they had learned things that they had never fathomed.
是的，没错。那很对。好吧，你是怎么知道的，比如，你让他们下载了他们学到的东西吗？我的意思是，我女儿和她最好的朋友艾米丽回家了，她们惊呆了。她们学到了她们从未想象过的事情。
Mom, there's not a stork involved at all. There's no birds. No, but they had taught them about venereal disease and all different kinds of sex. You know, it was like very, very comprehensive. And so they were a bit stunned. I tried with my 14-year-old. And then, pardon the term here, but aborted.
妈妈，根本没有鹳鸟参与。没有鸟。不，但他们教了她们关于性病和各种各样的性知识。你知道，这非常、非常全面。所以她们有点惊呆了。我试着和我14岁的孩子谈。然后，请原谅这个词，但流产了。
When I kind of got off the rails a little bit, because I got to the point of explaining, I got right up to ejaculation, and I didn't want to use that word or be any more specific about that moment. So I just said that the penis is so happy about the connection that it screams into the woman. Huh.
当我有点偏离轨道时，因为我解释到了那个点，我直接解释到了射精，我不想用那个词或者对那一刻更具体。所以我只是说阴茎对这种连接感到非常高兴，以至于它在女人体内尖叫。嗯。
That's even more terrifying. It is. Well, that's why I pulled the ripcord and the penis scream. I turd up the radio. I want to pull the ripcord. This is one of the worst, and then the dick barfed. Like, that would have been better. That's the boy version.
那更可怕。确实。好吧，这就是为什么我拉了拉绳，阴茎尖叫。我调大了收音机。我想拉拉绳。这是最糟糕的之一，然后阴茎呕吐了。就像，那会更好。那是男孩版本。
Jesus Christ, baby. I have girls. Oh my God. I know. Gwyneth, I want to ask you a question about Goop. Go ahead. Please do. Now, I've been to the website.
天哪，宝贝。我有女孩。哦，天哪。我知道。格温妮丝，我想问你一个关于Goop的问题。请问。请务必问。现在，我去过那个网站。
It's fantastic. Thank you. It is the idea behind Goop, that it's like an Amazon site kind of for women, because remember, for those who are listening, there's this deli in town called Jerry's Deli. And when you go there, you open the menu and there's thousands of things you can,
太棒了。谢谢。Goop背后的想法是它像是一个女性的亚马逊网站吗？因为记住，对于那些正在听的人，城里有一家熟食店叫杰瑞熟食店。当你去那里时，你打开菜单，有成千上万的东西你可以，
or you're gonna get anything you want at this deli. And that's kind of what I thought of when I went to Goop for the first time. I was like, oh, wow, you can get, you literally can get anything. She loves that comparison. Jerry's Deli. It is the Jerry's.
或者你可以在这家熟食店得到任何你想要的。这就是我第一次去Goop时想到的。我想，哦，哇，你可以得到，你真的可以得到任何东西。她喜欢那个比较。杰瑞熟食店。它是杰瑞的。
Jerry's Deli is the greatest deli in the world. A female lifestyle. It is. It is. Guy Starkman's just elated. No, I think, first of all, that's really good feedback, because also we've been trying to work on clarifying the offering a little bit.
杰瑞熟食店是世界上最棒的熟食店。女性生活方式。它是。它是。盖伊·斯塔克曼只是欣喜若狂。不，我认为，首先，那是很好的反馈，因为我们也一直在努力澄清我们的产品。
And when I started, I just was super interested in connecting people to interesting things and great doctors or tacos or whatever the case may be. And because I didn't conceive of it as a business when I launched it, and I was talking about a variety of subjects, I kind of had the latitude to go into a lot of different verticals
当我开始时，我只是超级有兴趣将人们与有趣的事物和伟大的医生或塔可饼或任何情况联系起来。因为我在推出它时并没有把它视为一项业务，而且我谈论了各种各样的主题，所以我有一种自由去进入许多不同的垂直领域，
when we started to monetize. So we could do a men's sweatshirt or a clean deodorant or stuff to make recipes with. And so yes, I think that kind of the overarching theme is we have tools and products and content to help people really optimize their lives. And I think because it's a lifestyle brand, we can kind of sell a lot,
当我们开始盈利时。所以我们可以做男士运动衫或清洁除臭剂或制作食谱的东西。所以是的，我认为总的主题是我们有工具、产品和内容来帮助人们真正优化他们的生活。而且我认为因为它是一个生活方式品牌，我们可以卖很多，
but also we don't want it to be overwhelming and confusing. So actually we're in the process right now of streamlining a little bit. Has Sean's question made you, are you gonna have like a conference call after this and be like, guys, we need to change her approach? No, I was gonna. We need better size.
但我们也不希望它让人不知所措和困惑。所以实际上我们现在正在精简一点。肖恩的问题让你，你之后会开电话会议说，伙计们，我们需要改变她的方法吗？不，我本来要。我们需要更好的尺寸。
I was gonna say, behind any brand that you've built is a trust from the consumers. And you've built this trust that Gwyneth Paltrow and the brand Goop, you can trust that anything you go to get there is gonna be fucking awesome. You're curating what you think of whatever sort of area what you think is the best product for this particular need.
我本来要说，任何你建立的品牌背后都是消费者的信任。你建立了这种信任，即格温妮丝·帕特洛和Goop品牌，你可以相信你去那里得到的任何东西都会他妈的棒极了。你在策划你认为的任何领域，你认为最适合这个特定需求的产品。
Right. And some of those products we make and some of them we buy like amazing brands that we find that we fall in love with that adhered to our standards of non-toxic, et cetera. And when you started it, where did the idea come from? What was the inspiration and like, were you like, I gotta get, like you said,
对。其中一些产品是我们制造的，一些是我们购买的，比如我们发现的我们爱上的惊人品牌，它们坚持我们的无毒标准等等。当你开始它时，这个想法从哪里来？灵感是什么，比如你是否像你说的那样，
I kind of take a, I need to take a break from acting or whatever and really delve into this. Or was it just something that you kind of did on the side that became something? You know, it's funny, when I was little, I really, really, really wanted to be an actress. And that is because I grew up watching Blythe Danner rehearse Masha and the Three Sisters or Blanche Dubois
我需要从演戏中休息一下或者其他什么，真正深入研究这个。还是这只是你顺便做的事情，后来变成了某种东西？你知道，很有趣，当我小的时候，我真的、真的、真的想成为一名演员。这是因为我从小看着布莱丝·丹纳排练《玛莎和三姐妹》或《欲望号街车》中的布兰奇，
or all of these like, or, you know, Shakespeare in the park. Like I grew up watching this woman fully inhabit herself and her power on stage. And I thought like, gosh, I want to be like that. And so that's what you do in order to, as a woman, you know, especially at that time, you didn't see a lot of, you know, even on Wall Street, like the women who are on Wall Street
或者所有这些，或者，你知道，公园里的莎士比亚。我从小看着这个女人在舞台上完全沉浸在自己和她的力量中。我想，天哪，我想成为那样的人。所以这就是你为了，作为一个女人，你知道，特别是在那个时候，你没有看到很多，你知道，即使在华尔街，那些在华尔街的女性，
were sort of approximating a male, you know, that male archetypal thing instead of doing it as a woman. And I saw my mother in all of her femininity and talent, like just being incredible. So I thought that's what I wanted to do. And so that's what I started to do. And I- Nailed it.
都在某种程度上模仿男性，你知道，那种男性原型，而不是以女性的方式去做。我看到我母亲展现出她所有的女性气质和才华，就像简直不可思议。所以我认为那就是我想做的。所以我开始那样做。而且我——做到了。
Yeah. Thank you. To say the least, yeah. I had a lot of success, but I'm also really a homebody. And I love my family and I've had all my best friends, either since kindergarten or seventh grade, when I moved schools, like I was lonely being, you know, in a hotel room in Toronto ordering room service
是的。谢谢。至少可以这么说，是的。我取得了很大的成功，但我也是一个非常顾家的人。我爱我的家人，我所有的最好的朋友，要么是从幼儿园要么是从七年级开始，当我转学时，就像我在多伦多的酒店房间里感到孤独，点客房服务，
and all my friends were, you know, in New York or in call, you know, and I just felt like a little bit of a fish out of water. And so that feeling grew and then once I had my daughter, I was like, I can't, I just can't, I can't do this. Like I can't leave her. For three, four months in a trailer. I just can't do it.
而我所有的朋友都在，你知道，在纽约或在，你知道，我只是觉得有点像离水的鱼。所以那种感觉增长了，然后一旦我有了女儿，我就想，我不能，我只是不能，我不能这样做。就像我不能离开她。在拖车里待三、四个月。我只是做不到。
I can't. But you did see your mom manage an ability to take you with her when she was on location, yes? Yeah, but I think she also gave up a lot of amazing film roles. Like if I told you guys some of the parts that she passed on, like you would, you wouldn't believe it. It's pretty great.
我不能。但你确实看到你妈妈设法带你一起去，当她在外景地时，对吧？是的，但我想她也放弃了很多很棒的电影角色。如果我告诉你们她错过的一些角色，你们会，你们不会相信的。这很棒。
It's pretty crazy. I'm sure. Because of us. And then every summer she would go to the Williamson Theatre Festival and she would do one or two plays and we would all go and we would go to camp and we had the best time in the summers doing that.
这很疯狂。我相信。因为我们。然后每年夏天她都会去威廉斯敦戏剧节，她会演一两部戏，我们都会去，我们会去露营，我们在夏天做那些事度过了最美好的时光。
And then she would try to do movies that were in LA or TV, you know, she was very cognizant of not, you know, going to Europe for four months to film and leaving us at home. I mean, I think she did it a couple of times. She did a mini-series once in Germany and the UK. But then we got to go over there and see her. But you know how it is.
然后她会尝试拍在洛杉矶或电视上的电影，你知道，她非常清楚不要，你知道，去欧洲拍四个月电影把我们留在家里。我的意思是，我想她确实做过几次。她有一次在德国和英国拍了一部迷你剧。但后来我们有机会去那里看她。但你知道是怎么回事。
It's some, if you have little kids, it's hard to go, you know. Especially once you guys get into school too and you've got a social continuity that you want to, you know. I just, yeah, that's something that, I know that Jason, as another person who's got kids that I know, it's something that we're always, Jason, I was thinking the other day about when we were like in our early thirties and we were just stuff
如果你们有小孩，很难去，你知道。特别是当你们开始上学时，你们有想要保持的社会连续性，你知道。我只是，是的，那是，我知道杰森，作为另一个我知道有孩子的人，这是我们总是，杰森，我前几天在想，当我们三十出头时，我们只是，
what happened, we'd like do whatever because we had no kids, we had no responsibilities. And now everything is always seen through the lens of does it work for my kids? Like, you know. Yeah, them first. Like some, I was, reason I was going to go to Toronto to do this thing.
发生了什么，我们会做任何事，因为我们没有孩子，我们没有责任。现在一切总是通过它是否适合我的孩子来观察？就像，你知道。是的，她们第一。就像一些，我当时，我去多伦多做这件事的原因。
And I'm like, I can't go right now because I can't go to quarantine. I can't be away from my kids and I can't be away for 14 or I can't have, not have the ability to come home on the weekend, like there's no, there's just no way it's out of the question. It's a non-starter, can't do it, next. Yeah, exactly.
我说，我现在不能去，因为我不能去隔离。我不能离开我的孩子，我不能离开14天，或者我不能，没有能力在周末回家，就像没有，根本不可能，这不在考虑范围内。这是一个非启动项，做不到，下一个。是的，完全正确。
Direct everything. So then because of that, you kind of felt that being at home, you wanted to begin another kind of dream of yours or something that you were drawn to. Well, I was always so passionate about cooking and traveling and discovering things. And when I had done films and far flung places I had kind of cracked the cities and I had notebooks full
直接一切。所以因为那个，你觉得待在家里，你想要开始你的另一个梦想或者你被吸引的东西。好吧，我一直对烹饪、旅行和发现事物充满热情。当我拍完电影和去遥远的地方时，我已经破解了这些城市，我有笔记本，装满了
of, you know, I would ask like, like when I was shooting the talented Mr. Ripley, we were in Naples and the hotel concierge, I said, where's the best place to get pizza? And the concierge told me three places. And then I asked the camera truck driver, where's the best place to get pizza? Totally different answer.
你知道，我会问，比如当我拍摄《天才瑞普利》时，我们在那不勒斯，酒店礼宾部，我说，哪里是吃披萨最好的地方？礼宾部告诉了我三个地方。然后我问摄像卡车司机，哪里是吃披萨最好的地方？完全不同的答案。
And that guy's pizza was a million times better. So I was like, to where is there getting hosed by their, you know, concierge? Like this isn't the right place to go. And so I started, you know, aggregating all that information and then sharing it with my friends. And I just get so much pleasure out of that. Is Goop International as well?
那个家伙的披萨比那个好一百万倍。所以我当时想，那些被他们的礼宾部坑的人——这不是去的地方。所以我开始，你知道，汇总所有这些信息，然后与我的朋友分享。我只是从中得到很多乐趣。Goop也是国际化的吗？
Like in other words, like if I go to Peru and I want to know where to get, you know, a good sweater, like is there... I don't know if we have a, well, I think we have a Peru guide. It's pretty international. There's some areas we haven't covered, but it's all the major cities are covered for sure.
换句话说，如果我去秘鲁，我想知道去哪里买，你知道，一件好的毛衣，有吗……我不知道我们是否有，好吧，我想我们有秘鲁指南。它相当国际化。有些领域我们还没有覆盖，但所有主要城市肯定都覆盖了。
Wow. Do you guys cover like drugs too? Oh. Yeah, we do. Psychedelics and absolutely, absolutely for sure. Wait, speaking of which, I heard, isn't there, is it true that they're, I apologize, I have not done great research? I don't.
哇。你们也覆盖像毒品这样的东西吗？哦。是的，我们覆盖。迷幻药，绝对，绝对肯定。等等，说到这个，我听说，不是吗，是真的吗，他们，我道歉，我没有做很好的研究？我不。
If I had, I would have seen the Goop show on Netflix, but I hear on that either you take psychedelics or somebody does and yeah. So one of the episodes was, you know, it's actually a really, really fascinating field and it's emerging for trauma, for healing trauma. So there's a well-established organization called MAPS, a Multidisciplinary Association of Psychedelic Studies,
如果我做了，我就看过Netflix上的Goop节目了，但我听说在那上面要么你服用迷幻药，要么有人服用，是的。所以其中一集是，你知道，这实际上是一个非常、非常迷人的领域，它正在为创伤，为治愈创伤而兴起。所以有一个完善的组织叫MAPS，多学科迷幻研究协会，
and they're going through a trial with the FDA right now with veterans and it's really, really incredible. Like their people are taking MDMA, medical grade MDMA or psilocybin, which is mushrooms, and being able to heal incredible deep trauma and being able to get off other antidepressants or feeling less suicidal. So this is really going to be the emerging modality.
他们现在正在与退伍军人进行FDA试验，这真的、真的不可思议。就像他们的人正在服用MDMA，医疗级MDMA或裸盖菇素，也就是蘑菇，并且能够治愈不可思议的深层创伤，并且能够停止服用其他抗抑郁药或感觉不那么自杀。所以这真的会成为新兴的模式。
Yeah, I've heard so much about it. Is it micro dosing or is it controlled full trips? So in the case of the MDMA, it's a high dose with the practitioner and the therapist there. So micro dosing psilocybin has been shown to really help with depression and that's a micro dose. So people take micro dose, you know, and they are, their outlook on life is really changing
是的，我听说了很多关于它的事。是微剂量还是受控的全面旅行？所以在MDMA的情况下，这是在从业者和治疗师在场的情况下进行的高剂量。所以裸盖菇素的微剂量已被证明确实有助于抑郁症，那是一个微剂量。所以人们服用微剂量，你知道，他们是，他们对生活的看法真的在改变，
and they're studying that right now as well, which is pretty cool. I know, I got prescribed glow sticks by my doctor two weeks ago. No, no, that's a different thing. It's a different. And a rave, rave and glow sticks. But it does, I do know a couple of people who are micro dosing
而且他们现在也在研究那个，这很酷。我知道，我医生两周前给我开了荧光棒。不，不，那是另一回事。那是不同的。还有狂欢，狂欢和荧光棒。但我确实，我确实认识几个人在服用微剂量，
and it seems to have had really good effects. And I guess they've been doing it for a while now and they talk about the fact that they're not, they don't feel high at all. They don't feel out of it, but they just don't, they were able to get off other prescription meds, which I think is really the direction we should be going in. And did you do this on the show, Gwyneth?
而且它似乎有很好的效果。我想他们现在已经做了一段时间了，他们谈论的事实是他们没有，他们根本不觉得嗨。他们不觉得神志不清，但他们只是不，他们能够停止服用其他处方药，我认为这确实是我们应该前进的方向。你在节目中做了这个吗，格温妮丝？
I did not, but some of my team did. I did not. But on one episode, the psychedelics episode, some of our team from Goop went to Jamaica and did psilocybin. So. I've not yet returned, I heard. They've not yet returned. Can not be found missing.
我没有，但我的一些团队做了。我没有。但在其中一集，迷幻药那一集，我们Goop的一些团队去了牙买加，服用了裸盖菇素。所以。我听说他们还没回来。他们还没回来。找不到，失踪了。
You said tried psilocybin, you mean they just took shrooms? They took shrooms, that's right. But in a therapeutic setting. I guess. Yeah, because I don't want to puke. I don't want to like get. Is that code for a bean bag? What's a therapeutic setting?
你说尝试裸盖菇素，你是说他们只是吃了蘑菇？他们吃了蘑菇，没错。但在治疗环境中。我想。是的，因为我不想呕吐。我不想像那样。那是懒人沙发的代码吗？什么是治疗环境？
Pretty much. All right, now let's say Apple comes to you and she says she wants to be an actress or maybe she is already, I apologize. What do you say to that? Well, you know, I think parenting is such an interesting exploration of your own projections and judgments and et cetera, right?
差不多。好吧，现在假设苹果来找你，她说她想成为一名演员，或者也许她已经是了，我道歉。你对此怎么说？好吧，你知道，我认为育儿是对你自己的投射和判断等等的有趣探索，对吧？
So I think my goal with both my children all the time is to try to create an environment where they feel that they are accepted for who they are. And so I try not to steer them towards or away from anything. Because I think implicit in that is I'm judging you for your choice. That's a mistake.
所以我认为我和我的两个孩子一直以来的目标是尝试创造一个环境，让他们觉得他们因为自己是谁而被接受。所以我尽量不引导他们走向或远离任何事情。因为我认为隐含在其中是我在评判你的选择。那是一个错误。
You heard Judge Bendy knew it was a negative. Yeah, yeah, they're not gonna have any fear of anything. Way to go. Fear is such a. But obviously she would look at your experience and go, well, this is, this would be safe. I've got a great example of success in this. And a lot of times that's kind of just the key.
你听到了法官Bendy知道那是一个负面的。是的，是的，他们不会对任何事情有恐惧。做得好。恐惧是如此的。但显然她会看你的经历，然后想，好吧，这，这会是安全的。我在这方面有一个成功的伟大例子。而且很多时候这只是关键。
If you just, if you don't have a barrier in front of it and you feel somewhat confident, nine times out of 10 you're gonna land on something pretty great. I mean, I think she'll be whatever she wants to be. And hopefully she'll, you know, I hope she's polite and happy and as normal as possible. And that she's self-aware and, you know, all those kinds of things.
如果你只是，如果你面前没有障碍，而且你感到有点自信，十有八九你会得到一些相当棒的东西。我的意思是，我认为她会成为她想成为的任何人。希望她会，你知道，我希望她有礼貌、快乐，尽可能正常。而且她有自我意识，你知道，所有那些事情。
And if she wants to act, then I'll totally support that. Your kids are starting to get to that age of college, right? And starting to think about like. Yeah, she's almost 17. Oh my God. She's a comedy-sized mug, by the way. Thank you. Can I get that on the website?
如果她想演戏，那么我会完全支持。你的孩子开始到上大学的年龄了，对吧？并开始考虑像。是的，她快17岁了。哦，天哪。顺便说一句，她是一个喜剧大小的杯子。谢谢。我能在网站上买到那个吗？
That is a good-looking coffee mug. That is a great mug. That is a really good mug. Actually, we don't sell these mugs. Yet. Yet, yet. I will. What about, I mean, I'm gonna be such a mess
那是一个好看的咖啡杯。那是一个很棒的杯子。那是一个非常好的杯子。其实，我们不卖这些杯子。还没。还没，还没。我会的。那，我的意思是，我会变得一团糟
when my kids go off to college. I'm not gonna be good at being an empty nester at all. I'm not sure what I'm gonna do. I'll be a rank. Why don't we all just- I can tell you what you're gonna do. What's that? Probably play golf like one more day a week
当我的孩子去上大学时。我根本不擅长做空巢老人。我不确定我会做什么。我会是一个等级。为什么我们不都——我可以告诉你你会做什么。那是什么？可能打高尔夫球每周多一天
than you already do. And sit where you're sitting. Jason's wife told me recently, she told me like, cause I talked to, I told Jason, I talked to Jason's wife a lot on the phone. In fact- Yeah, no. Amanda and I FaceTime a lot.
比你现在做的多。并坐在你坐的地方。杰森的妻子最近告诉我，她告诉我，因为我跟，我告诉杰森，我经常在电话里跟杰森的妻子说话。事实上——是的，不。阿曼达和我经常FaceTime。
You FaceTime a little bit more than I think is appropriate. Why don't you just call her? You don't need to be staring at each other when you're discussing things. We like to read. We're trying to read each other. We're having, it's called human connection, you weirdo. Pick it up in the voice instead.
你FaceTime的次数比我认为合适的要多一点。为什么你不直接打电话给她？当你讨论事情时，你不需要盯着对方看。我们喜欢阅读。我们试图阅读对方。我们正在进行，这叫人类连接，你这个怪胎。在声音里感受它吧。
She said, she said, she goes, I don't mind that you guys are playing so much golf, but I don't want him to get soft. And I was like, too late, you know? I mean, let's be real. Golf fun. Yeah, we got the golf thing. But having the kids go away,
她说，她说，她说，我不介意你们打那么多高尔夫球，但我不想让他变软。我当时想，太晚了，你知道？我的意思是，让我们现实一点。高尔夫很有趣。是的，我们有高尔夫球。但让孩子们离开，
that is something that you're staring down the barrel of in the next couple of years, right? Sorry, I don't want to cause it- No, it's okay. If I cry for you- Would love to get you crying. I don't think we've had a crying guest yet. That would be great.
那是你在未来几年里盯着枪管的事情，对吧？抱歉，我不想引起——不，没关系。如果我为你哭——很想让你哭。我想我们还没有哭过的嘉宾。那会很棒。
Yeah, let's guys, let's work on that. Keep going well. Here's the thing. We know she's won an Academy Award amongst other things. We know you could cry, but we want real- She could fake it real easy. Based on your own life, tears, if that's okay. Do you have a strategy for the emptiness thing?
是的，伙计们，让我们努力做到这一点。继续，格温妮丝。事情是这样的。我们知道她赢得了奥斯卡奖，除其他事项外。我们知道你能哭，但我们想要真实的——她可以很容易地假装。基于你自己的生活，眼泪，如果可以的话。你对空虚的事情有策略吗？
Have you decided what you're gonna do about it? This is good, keep going. I mean, psilocybin, a lot of psilocybin. Psilocybin. I'm gonna do a lot of psilocybin. There we go. Good idea. You know what I think the strategy might be is
你决定好要怎么做了吗？这很好，继续。我的意思是，裸盖菇素，大量的裸盖菇素。裸盖菇素。我要做大量的裸盖菇素。这就对了。好主意。你知道我认为策略可能是什么吗？
maybe move to a different house. Just outside the university? Exactly, like I could go pretty near where she's gonna go to college and then I don't have to walk by an empty bedroom or anything like that. Yeah, move into like a two bedroom apartment. I'm considering that. You know what's so funny, when I was in college,
也许搬到不同的房子。就在大学外面？完全正确，我可以去她要上大学的地方附近，然后我就不必走过空卧室什么的了。是的，搬进像两居室的公寓。我正在考虑那个。你知道什么很有趣，当我在大学时，
I used to call my mom at like one or two in the morning because I had no consideration for her sleep pattern. And every time she would answer the phone, she'd go, hello, hello, hello? And I'd go, mom, are you sleeping? No, I'm up, I'm up, what's up, I'm up. I was like, well, it's not a sign of weakness if you're sleeping, just call me back.
我过去常在凌晨一点或两点给我妈妈打电话，因为我根本不考虑她的睡眠模式。每次她接电话，她都会说，喂，喂，喂？我会说，妈妈，你在睡觉吗？不，我醒着，我醒着，怎么了，我醒着。我当时想，好吧，如果你在睡觉，这不是软弱的标志，只是回电话给我。
Like she was like wanted to be like the best perfect mom everywhere all the time. And I was such an asshole for calling her two in the morning but I would have all the time. Well, she liked to keep an eye on you, dude, come on. Gwyneth, my mom grew up with one eye, so that was that joke. You know, Gwyneth, I'm looking at you drinking that coffee,
就像她想要成为到处都完美的妈妈一样。我真是个混蛋，在凌晨两点给她打电话，但我一直都会。好吧，她喜欢盯着你，伙计，得了吧。格温妮丝，我妈妈长着一只眼睛长大，所以那是那个笑话。你知道，格温妮丝，我看着你喝那杯咖啡，
it makes me think, you're probably the one person, yeah, exactly, the one person I know that might not have a vice. Not tea. Wait, wait, wait, wait. Do you have a vice? It's like a matcha. You're gonna guess what the vice is or what's in the, oh.
这让我想到，你可能是唯一一个人，是的，完全正确，我知道的唯一一个人可能没有恶习。不是茶。等等，等等，等等，等等。你有恶习吗？就像抹茶。你要猜恶习是什么或者杯子里有什么，哦。
I'm trying to guess what she's drinking. Oh, I know what it is, it's green tea. No, she said it's not tea. Oh, it's not tea. It's yerba mate. No. It's hot, hot, hot water and lemon with a sneeze of honey.
我正在试着猜她在喝什么。哦，我知道是什么，是绿茶。不，她说不是茶。哦，不是茶。是马黛茶。不。是热、热、热的水和柠檬，加一点蜂蜜。
You are maxing out what we know about alternative cool beverages. It's way goopier, exactly, it's goopier than juice. Mushroom, it's mushroom tea, not the psilocybin stuff. Racy, no, that's not it. No, no, it's like root of something. It's like root of psilocybin. It's eye of newt, wing of bat.
你正在最大限度地利用我们所知道的替代性酷饮料。它更Goop，完全正确，它比果汁更Goop。蘑菇，是蘑菇茶，不是裸盖菇素那种。Racy，不，不是那个。不，不，它像某种根。它像裸盖菇素的根。它是蝾螈的眼睛，蝙蝠的翅膀。
Nailed it. DmT, it's pure DMT. It's bone broth. Of course, it's bone broth. What kind of bones? Are you being serious? Is it really bone broth? What kind of bone?
做到了。DmT，是纯DMT。是骨汤。当然，是骨汤。什么样的骨头？你是认真的吗？真的是骨汤吗？什么样的骨头？
Skeleton bone. Human bone? Yes. Human bone. That's why she looks so good, guys. Goop is extreme. We just confirmed QAnon that we really said we're... Exactly, that's what I was gonna say this evening.
骨架骨。人骨？是的。人骨。这就是为什么她看起来这么好，伙计们。Goop是极端的。我们刚刚确认了QAnon，我们真的说我们是……完全正确，这就是我今晚要说的。
No, it's chicken broth. It's bone broth. But we used to, that's what we used to call when you have too many dudes in a hot tub, we'd call it bone broth. Yeah. Our last Saturday in my case. What about a vice, Gwyneth?
不，是鸡汤。是骨汤。但我们过去常，当我们有太多人在热水浴缸里时，我们过去常叫它骨汤。是的。在我这个案例中，我们上周六。那恶习呢，格温妮丝？
I wanna know, do you have one? Oh, yeah. Um, well, I used to have many more vices. Like, I really loved cigarettes. Like, loved. Me too. Loved, I miss it. Do you still miss it?
我想知道，你有吗？哦，是的。嗯，好吧，我过去有很多恶习。比如，我真的很喜欢香烟。比如，喜欢。我也是。喜欢，我想念它。你还想念它吗？
I still... Every once in a while. Every once in a while. I mean, I haven't smoked in a really long time now, but every once in a while. You haven't had one? You know, I quit my, like, pack-a-day habit when I was probably 24 years old.
我仍然……偶尔。偶尔。我的意思是，我现在已经很久没抽烟了，但偶尔。你没抽过吗？你知道，我大概在24岁时戒掉了我那种一天一包的习惯。
And then I didn't smoke for a long, long time, and then I did a movie called The Royal Tenenbombs, where I had to smoke in the movie. And I was like, oh, this is quite nice. And then I would smoke a little bit. And then I stopped. And then I did The Talented Mr. Ripley, where I had to smoke.
后来我有很长很长一段时间没抽烟，后来我拍了一部电影叫《天才一族》，我在电影里必须抽烟。当时我就想，哦，这感觉还挺不错的。于是我就又抽了一点。后来我又戒了。再后来我拍了《天才瑞普利》，我在里面也得抽烟。
So I would maybe, you know, I had a long time of not smoking, and then maybe having one every once in a while. And then I had my kids and didn't smoke forever. And then maybe for a couple years after that, maybe one at a party, like one a year, or something like that. That wouldn't get you nauseous? No.
所以我可能，你知道，我有很长一段时间没抽，然后偶尔会抽上一根。后来我有了孩子，就彻底不抽了。在那之后的几年里，可能一年在派对上抽一根，诸如此类的。那不会让你觉得恶心吗？不会。
No, I loved it. But now I haven't smoked in years. And I do miss it, because I just, you know, I think it's our generation too, right? It was like, it somehow didn't, hopefully, sink in how bad for us it was. It's also social, right? It's a social thing.
不会，我很喜欢。但现在我已经好几年没抽烟了。我确实有点怀念，因为我只是，你知道，我觉得这也是我们这一代人的通病，对吧？当时好像，希望如此，没意识到这对我们有多不好。这也是一种社交，对吧？这是一种社交活动。
And it was so, I don't know, I was like, at first thing in the morning with a cup of coffee and a cigarette, which is so gross, by the way. Like, that is gross. Well, I guess, I guess it's gross. Let me just say this. Here's a little update. I'm gonna give you guys a little spoiler alert.
而且当时，我不知道，我当时就像，每天早上第一件事就是喝杯咖啡抽根烟，顺便说一下，这太恶心了。真的，那很恶心。好吧，我想，我想这确实很恶心。让我这么说吧。这里有个小更新。我要给你们一个小剧透。
Smoking, still cool. Next subject. Okay. No, you know, I used to be like, I used to smoke a lot. I don't smoke that much anymore, but I do. Oh, I don't know about that. Okay, well. Every time we, I chat with Will,
抽烟，还是很酷。下一个话题。好吧。不，你知道，我以前，我以前抽很多烟。我现在抽得没那么多了，但我确实还在抽。哦，我对此表示怀疑。好吧，好吧。每次我们，我和威尔聊天，
like on a FaceTime or something, and he has a cigarette, I always start with, oh, good, you're still smoking? Good, that's the only reason I was calling. Right. But I like alcohol, but also, I've been on this, like, you know, I've been super, I don't know, I've been on a bit of a clean out since,
比如在FaceTime或者其他什么地方，他抽着烟，我总是以“哦，太好了，你还在抽烟？好，这就是我打电话的唯一原因”开头。对。但我喜欢酒精，而且，我一直处于这种，你知道，我一直超级，我不知道，我一直在进行某种清理，自从，
basically during quarantine, I was drinking seven nights a week and making pasta and eating bread. Like, I went totally off the rails. I mean, who drinks multiple drinks seven nights a week? Like, that's not healthy. Gwyneth Paltrow does. I know.
基本上在隔离期间，我每周七个晚上都在喝酒，做意大利面，吃面包。我完全失控了。我是说，谁会每周七个晚上都喝好几杯酒？那不健康。格温妮丝·帕特洛会。我知道。
During quarantine. But no, wait, what does this look like? Are we talking about like a nice wine or are you just going for the cheap hard stuff? Whisky, like I love whiskey, so I would have like, and I make this fantastic drink called the Buster Paltrow, which I named after my grandfather, who loved whiskey sours.
在隔离期间。但等等，等等，这看起来是什么样的？我们说的是那种好酒，还是你只是在喝廉价的烈酒？威士忌，我喜欢威士忌，所以我会有，而且我做了一种很棒的饮料叫“巴斯特·帕特洛”，这是以我祖父的名字命名的，他喜欢威士忌酸酒。
And it's this great quinoa whiskey from this distillery in Tennessee with maple syrup and lemon juice, and it's just heaven. And I would like have two of those every night of quarantine, basically. Well, nobody knew what was happening. You were living your best life, and it sounded like you were spending a lot of time
这是一种来自田纳西州一家酿酒厂的很棒的藜麦威士忌，加了枫糖浆和柠檬汁，简直是天堂。在隔离期间，我基本上每晚都要喝两杯。好吧，没人知道发生了什么。你过着最好的生活，听起来你花了很多时间
with dandies. If you're going to spend time with dandies, you're going to have a lot of cocktails. By the way, I make dandies a Buster Paltrow every Sunday, so he knows exactly what I'm talking about. But wait, so two drinks, what do two drinks do to you? Do you remember going to bed every night? Of course, I'm not like blackout, but...
和花花公子们在一起。如果你要和花花公子们在一起，你肯定会喝很多鸡尾酒。顺便说一下，我每个周日都给花花公子们做“巴斯特·帕特洛”，所以他很清楚我在说什么。但等等，两杯酒，两杯酒对你有什么影响？你记得每天晚上上床睡觉吗？当然，我不会喝到断片，但是……
But some people, their tolerance is low, I guess if you're doing it every night. So wait, would three or four get you into a blackout? I don't, that's too much, I wouldn't know. I need to know what's gonna get you into a blackout. Why do you need to know? Yeah, why do you need to know? It sounds like I'm trying to know.
但有些人，他们的耐受力很低，我想如果你每晚都喝的话。所以等等，三四杯会让你断片吗？我不知道，那太多了，我不知道。我需要知道什么会让你断片。你为什么需要知道？是啊，你为什么需要知道？听起来像是我在试图了解。
Because I'm fascinated with people's tolerance. Some people, they can just drink, drink, or smoke a bunch of weed, it never affects them. And then other people, they just get around it and they get crazy. Yeah, I'm not like that. Yeah, I mean, you seem like we've met a few times and you're always so wonderful and warm and kind
因为我对人们的耐受力很着迷。有些人，他们就是能喝，或者抽很多大麻，从来不会影响他们。而另一些人，他们只要一碰，就会变得疯狂。是啊，我不是那样。是啊，我是说，你看起来，我们见过几次面，你总是那么棒、温暖、善良，
and inviting and in control and calm and have a light around you. And is that like, what makes you fall apart? Like I can't imagine you falling apart of the scene. I do, I fall, you know, what makes me fall apart the most is I mean, I think I'm not great at taking kind of emotional inventory all the time. I think I'm a good white knuckler.
而且热情、有控制力、冷静，周围散发着光芒。那是，什么会让你崩溃？我无法想象你崩溃的样子。我会，我会，你知道，最让我崩溃的是，我想我不擅长一直进行某种情绪盘点。我觉得我是一个很能忍的人。
Like I'm like, I can fucking do it. I can get through it, like I can, you know, and then so there will be a cumulative effect there where I'm like, I... Do you snap at that moment? Yeah, I can't see you getting mad. Like I'll cry, I'm not a mad, like I'll be passive aggressive or I'll be like, you know, my kids will come to the kitchen
就像我，我可以他妈的做到。我可以挺过去，我可以，你知道，所以会有累积效应，我会，我……你在那一刻会发火吗？是啊，我无法想象你生气。我会哭，我不是那种会生气的人，我会消极抵抗，或者我会，你知道，我的孩子们会来到厨房，
in the middle of it and I'll be like, I'm on a phone call guys, like do you see, you know what I mean? So I'll be a little shot tempered. Monster. But I'm not, I don't snap, like I don't yell. I'm never, I turn into like the waspy side of me. I'm half Jewish and half, I go wasp. I go like cold, internal.
在中间，我会说，我在打电话，伙计们，你们没看见吗，你知道我的意思吗？所以我脾气会有点急。怪物。但我不会，我不会发火，我不会大喊大叫。我从来不会，我变成了那种盎格鲁-撒克逊白人新教徒的一面。我有一半犹太血统，一半，我变成了盎格鲁-撒克逊白人新教徒。我变得冷漠、内向。
I just like shut down, no anger, no outburst. Have you ever seen Jason if somebody forgets to charge his Tesla? Have you ever seen that? No. That wasn't a high point for me, okay? It was after a really bad round of golf. You wanna run.
我只是，你知道，关闭自己，没有愤怒，没有爆发。你见过杰森如果有人忘了给他的特斯拉充电吗？你见过吗？没有。那对我来说不是什么高光时刻，好吗？那是在一场非常糟糕的高尔夫球赛之后。你想跑。
You wanna run. Wait, now are you, if you don't snap, does that mean that your kids kind of know that push comes to shove, we're gonna, we need not worry about mom. Like are they, I feel like kids might need to be afraid of consequences a little bit. I mean, are you a pushover?
你想跑。等等，现在你是，如果你不发火，那是不是意味着你的孩子们知道，如果真的到了紧要关头，我们，我们不需要担心妈妈。就像他们，我觉得孩子们可能需要对后果有一点点恐惧。我是说，你是个软柿子吗？
Or do you? No, not at all. And they know, I think they're recalibrated, right? I think every kid is really smart at understanding what their parents triggers are and the moods are, and they're so tuned into us. I think, you know, they said to me the other day actually that I'm, they're like, you can be so scary
还是你？不，一点也不。他们知道，我想他们重新校准了，对吧？我想每个孩子都很聪明，能理解他们父母的触发点和情绪，他们和我们调频一致。我想，你知道，他们前几天实际上对我说了，我，他们说，你可能会很吓人，
and because you're quiet. So. Call them before the storm, yeah. But I don't, I didn't. No, what about your, what about your dude? Is he the disciplinarian in the house? I mean, our approach is like be super honest, super transparent with the kids always. And like, if something's, and also now they're all 15,
因为你很安静。所以。暴风雨前的宁静，是啊。但我没有，我没有。不，那你的，那你的男人呢？他是家里的纪律执行者吗？我是说，我们的方法是，对孩子们总是超级诚实，超级透明。而且，如果有什么事，而且现在他们都15岁了，
16, 17, we have four together. So they're pretty well who they are. And there's not a lot of like deeply corrective stuff. You know, I think you wanna continue to guide your kids a little bit in, towards the right end. And I always think about like, who are we trying to put into the world when they're 18 and come at it from that point of view
16岁，17岁，我们总共有四个。所以他们基本上就是他们自己了。没有太多那种深度纠正的东西。你知道，我想你还是想在某种程度上引导你的孩子，朝着正确的方向。我总是想，当他们18岁时，我们试图把什么样的人带到这个世界上，并从那个角度出发，
as opposed to being reactive? Like I think our parents generation really parented out of instinct and I'm not sure that's the best way always. I think there could be, you know, it might be who our children to have for us to have some strategy and like big picture thinking around how to raise kids. It's funny, my parents came from the generation,
而不是被动反应？我觉得我们父母那一代人真的是凭本能养育孩子，我不确定那总是最好的方式。我觉得可能，你知道，对我们来说，有一些策略和宏观思考来养育孩子可能更好。真有趣，我的父母来自那一代，
I'm Canadian, but also very fairly, I guess, waspy background and they would say, it was a lot more of like, there are things you should and shouldn't do. You should be this way and you should not be this way. And it was like, well, what does that mean? And it wasn't tailored to your experience. It was, no, this is the way you behave
我是加拿大人，但也相当，我想，非常盎格鲁-撒克逊白人新教徒的背景，他们会说，更多的是，有些事情你应该做，有些不应该做。你应该这样，你不应该那样。就像，好吧，那是什么意思？这并不针对你的个人经历。而是，不，这就是你的行为方式，
and this is not the way you behave. And there were just absolutes in that way. And it doesn't allow for a lot of mistakes. Well, yeah. First of all, it doesn't allow for a lot of mistakes, but it also doesn't accommodate, you know, people's or kids' personalities or what they're going through.
这就是你不能有的行为方式。在那方面只有绝对。而且它不允许犯很多错误。好吧，是的。首先，它不允许犯很多错误，但它也不适应，你知道，人们或孩子们的个性，或者他们正在经历的事情。
And obviously that sort of shifted. I think that's a generational thing. Sort of, or the criteria has changed, right? It's like, now we're so helpful and we want to remove all their obstacles. And I'm not sure that the outcome of that is so great either. Exactly. So it's tough to try to, because you have that sounds like,
显然那种情况已经改变了。我认为那是一代人的事情。某种程度上，或者标准已经改变了，对吧？就像，现在我们太乐于助人了，我们想消除他们所有的障碍。我不确定这样做的结果有多好。确实。所以很难尝试，因为你有那种听起来像是，
well, I certainly have that instilled to me. And I know that there are parts of that that aren't necessarily right, but there are other parts of it that are good in terms of like, how do you become a member of society? Part of the greater good. I mean, again, this might be a Canadian idea, but this idea that we all have to contribute to this thing.
好吧，我当然有那种被灌输的东西。我知道其中有些部分不一定是对的，但其他部分在某种程度上是好的，比如，你如何成为社会的一员？为了更大的利益。我是说，再说一次，这可能是一个加拿大的想法，但这种我们都必须为这件事做出贡献的想法。
And so there are things that we have to do that aren't necessarily things that you want to do. So you want like, you got to pass the puck. You might want to shoot it, but you're saying. There's always that. But I think you can do that. Like you can explain, hey, this is why you might want to pass the puck,
所以有些事情我们必须做，而不一定是你想要做的。所以你想要，比如，你得传球。你可能想射门，但你是说。总是有那种情况。但我认为你可以做到。比如你可以解释，嘿，这就是为什么你可能想传球，
but without the shame that goes. I don't even know what that means. I know, I just love you said it. It's so good. Canadian parenting. It's like a hockey thing. It's I'm out. Okay, fine.
但没有那种羞耻感。我甚至不知道那是什么意思。我知道，我只是喜欢你说的。太好了。加拿大式育儿。就像冰球一样。我退出了。好吧，好吧。
But without shaming the child for the fact, you know, good people pass the puck. Like that is not the message that you want. It's like, hey, we live in a society where teamwork is a great thing. And this is totally normal. It might not be your instinct, but you'll find if you do pass the puck,
但不要因为事实而羞辱孩子，你知道，好人会传球。那不是你想要传达的信息。就像，嘿，我们生活在一个团队合作是一件伟大的事情的社会里。这完全正常。这可能不是你的本能，但你会发现如果你传球，
it's going to, you know, cultivate camaraderie and teamwork. You know what I mean? There's a way to do it. I think that's not like, you are a bad person for not passing the puck. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I think you're right. Do you find them more advanced than you were at that age?
它会，你知道，培养友情和团队精神。你知道我的意思吗？有一种方法可以做到。我认为那不是，你因为不传球就是一个坏人。是啊，是啊，是啊。我想你是对的。你觉得他们比你那个年纪时更先进吗？
Oh, beyond. They run circles. They run circles around me now. I'm 48. Like they're so much, I don't know. I can't believe you just said you're, I got to hang on a second. I need some bone broth.
哦，远不止。他们现在绕着我转。我48岁了。就像他们太，我不知道。我不敢相信你刚才说你，我得等一下。我需要一些骨汤。
Yeah. I want to ask a question about, for all the fans, including me of your acting, which I know we kind of touched on. Sure. You had said at somewhere, I forgot how you said it. It was so.
是啊。我想问一个问题，为了所有包括我在内的你的表演粉丝，我知道我们刚才触及到了。当然。你在某个地方说过，我忘了你是怎么说的了。太……
Take your time, Sean. Well, you abandoned acting. She's not busy. She only has a huge corporation to run. Yeah. Yeah, really drag it out. Get your thoughts together and then just sound it out.
慢慢来，肖恩。好吧，你放弃了表演。她不忙。她只是有一家大公司要经营。是啊。是啊，真的拖延时间。整理好你的想法，然后把它说出来。
Have you officially retired? Or is there something we can look forward to? Or for the people that missed you seeing you on screen, is there, are you only, would you only agree to something that's in town to film or and stuff like that? I probably wouldn't. I mean, the last time I starred in a movie,
你正式退休了吗？还是有什么我们可以期待的？或者对于那些错过在银幕上看到你的人，有没有，你只会同意在城里拍摄的东西，或者诸如此类的东西？我可能不会。我是说，我最后一次主演电影，
I've done good supporting parts in Iron Man, as you said, or this movie, Country Strong, that was only four weeks of shooting like 10 years ago. The last time I starred in a movie, I was pregnant with my daughter. So. Wow. So if my son goes to college
我在《钢铁侠》里演过很好的配角，正如你所说，或者这部电影，《乡谣情缘》，那只是10年前拍摄的四周时间。我最后一次主演电影时，我怀着我的女儿。所以。哇。所以如果我儿子上大学了，
and I feel the calling to do it, I think I would do it then. And in the meantime, well, we're doing another season of the Goop Lab on Netflix, which will come out next year. That's cool. And then, you know, if my husband wants me to do something that he's doing, I would probably do that.
而我感到有召唤去做这件事，我想那时我会做的。在此期间，好吧，我们正在Netflix上制作另一季《Goop实验室》，明年会出来。那很酷。然后，你知道，如果我丈夫想让我做他正在做的事情，我可能会做。
Because you're submissive and subservient to your man. We got it. We're gonna be right back after these messages. No, we're not gonna come back. If that's your question, we will never come back. If that's your actual question, we'll never come back. Just from a fan perspective, it's just, I want to see you do more.
因为你对你的男人顺从和服从。我们明白了。我们会在这些信息之后马上回来。不，我们不会回来的。如果那是你的问题，我们永远不会回来。如果那是你真正的问题，我们永远不会回来。只是从粉丝的角度来看，就是，我想看你做更多。
It's just that you're so talented. I'm so terrible. No. It's not my natural comfort. Like I don't. I know what you mean. I don't love it. I don't like being famous.
只是你太有才华了。我太糟糕了。不。这不是我自然的舒适区。就像我不。我知道你的意思。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢出名。
I don't like being, you know. But you do, it does seem like you do enjoy the position and the responsibility of leadership. Yeah? Yes, that's true. And I acknowledge that my fame has given me that platform. Like that's the platform from which I built this thing. So I'm not, you know, I'm not at all,
我不喜欢被，你知道。但你确实，看起来你确实享受领导的地位和责任。是吗？是的，那是真的。我承认我的名声给了我那个平台。那是建立这个东西的平台。所以我不是，你知道，我一点也不，
in any way minimizing the importance of it or value of it. But you've got that with you. But having said that, you also earned that because of your work. So there's nothing to be embarrassed or ashamed about. Like you earned that and it opened those doors in the same way that it does for lots of people in business for whatever it is they've come from.
以任何方式最小化它的重要性或价值。但你拥有它。但话虽如此，你也因为你的工作赢得了它。所以没什么好尴尬或羞耻的。你赢得了它，它打开了那些门，就像它为许多商业人士所做的那样，无论他们来自哪里。
So there's no shame in that. You earned it in that sense. And also I was gonna think, how funny is it or unexpected rather, that you started this company because you had all these ideas, these sort of creative ideas of what things that you want, products that you wanted to bring to market or things that you wanted to help people with
所以这没什么可羞耻的。从这个意义上说，你赢得了它。而且我也在想，你创办这家公司是多么有趣，或者更确切地说是出乎意料，因为你有所有这些想法，这些你想要的创造性想法，你想要推向市场的产品，或者你想要帮助人们的事情，
in certain areas. And then as a result of that, you actually have to get into the business side of it and be having all these calls about profit and loss and I'm sure employees and all this kind of shit. Interesting, great, not great could do without it. So, so interesting, so expanding, so hard, so educational, so inspiring, just a host of feelings
在某些领域。然后作为结果，你实际上必须进入它的商业方面，并进行所有这些关于损益的电话，我相信还有员工和所有这些狗屁东西。有趣，很好，不那么好，没有它也能行。所以，如此有趣，如此扩展，如此艰难，如此具有教育意义，如此鼓舞人心，只是一堆感受
and experiences that I just can't imagine. All founders have that in common. It's a very strange thing to pour yourself into something like that and then create a group of people to help you do that. And for me, it's like I love to learn. And so I've never learned more in trying to figure out how to do this job.
和经历，我简直无法想象。所有的创始人都对此有共同点。把你自己投入到那样的事情中，然后创造一群人来帮助你做这件事，这是一件非常奇怪的事情。对我来说，就像我喜欢学习。所以我在试图弄清楚如何做这份工作时，从来没有学到过更多。
I bet you would say no if I said, would you ever think about going into politics? But if a gun was to your head and you had to be the president of the United States, do you think, I mean, like there's no choice, you have to, it's done. Do you think that you would figure out how to enjoy it and be good at it for everyone in the country,
我敢打赌，如果我说，你会考虑从政吗，你会说不。但如果枪指着你的头，你必须成为美国总统，你认为，我是说，就像没有选择，你必须这样做，完成了。你认为你会想出如何享受它并为全国每个人做好它吗，
including those that you have absolutely no agreement with as far as politics? Because I guess that would be the ideal president, right? The president for everybody and figuring out how to balance everything and compromise and whatnot. I think I would be most interested in the people that I don't agree with.
包括那些你在政治上完全不同意的人？因为我想那会是理想的总统，对吧？为每个人服务的总统，并弄清楚如何平衡一切，妥协等等。我想我会对那些我不同意的人最感兴趣。
And I think I would learn the most from those people. I disagree. I think that when you get rhetoric out of the way, and you get this sort of like soapbox, righteous, didactic stuff out of the way, you're looking at a human being who is a thinking, feeling human being who has formed opinions based on
而且我想我会从那些人身上学到最多。我不同意。我认为当你摆脱了修辞，当你摆脱了这种像肥皂箱、正义、说教的东西，你看到的是一个有思想、有感情的人，他基于
a number of set of circumstances and criteria and- And they're chosen information. And like, how do you, there's so much more for us to learn through connection and understanding than anything else. So I think I would be a terrible president because I don't remember American history whatsoever. But if I was forced to, that would be my approach.
一系列的情况和标准形成了观点，而且——还有他们选择的信息。而且，就像，你怎么，我们通过联系和理解能学到的东西比其他任何东西都多。所以我认为我会是一个糟糕的总统，因为我根本不记得美国历史。但如果我被迫这样做，那会是我的方法。
I bet that would be successful. Because we're gonna force you. I agree. So the rest of your day today, you have Goop duties, parent duties, partner duties, what? I have, so we implemented a No Meetings Friday at Goop, which is fantastic. We did that too.
我敢打赌那会成功。因为我们要强迫你。我同意。所以你今天剩下的时间，你有Goop的职责，家长的职责，伴侣的职责，什么？我有，所以我们在Goop实施了周五无会议，这太棒了。我们也做了。
We just learned that. It's so great. So everybody can just kind of, so I have a lot of work to catch up on. We just came off of offsite last week and I have some planning and road mapping to do. And then I am gonna do that and pick up my son from school.
我们刚学到。太棒了。所以每个人都可以，所以我有大量的工作要赶上。我们上周刚结束了场外会议，我有一些计划和路线图要做。然后我会做那个，并从学校接我儿子。
He's just gone back, which is great. And then I'll- Is there cooking tonight? Actually, tonight, there's no cooking. My husband and I are going, we're going out to Malibu to eat at one of our favorite restaurants. Nice.
他刚回去，这很好。然后我会——今晚做饭吗？实际上，今晚，不做饭。我和我丈夫要去，我们要去马里布吃我们最喜欢的餐厅之一。不错。
God, I haven't been to a restaurant in so long. I miss it bad. So good. It's a plate. I don't know if you like oysters and stuff, but it's like a oyster bar and lobster rolls and cheese bar, I love that. Oh my God.
天哪，我好久没去餐厅了。我很想念它。太好了。这是一个盘子。我不知道你是否喜欢牡蛎之类的东西，但它就像一个牡蛎吧、龙虾卷和奶酪吧，我喜欢那个。哦，天哪。
It's so good. It sounds terrible. And when you eat outside. I love it. It sounds great. And a couple of drinks. You're gonna have a couple of cocktails. Why not?
太好了。听起来很糟糕。当你去外面吃的时候。我喜欢它。听起来很棒。还有几杯饮料。你要喝几杯鸡尾酒。为什么不呢？
Well, I've been really off the sauce, but I've been having a little bit here and there, but so maybe tonight. Maybe tonight I'm gonna release the hounds. You're gonna have a little bit of whiskey and some oysters. Sounds like a pretty long night for you tonight. Might want to sleep in tomorrow. I need, and I know you don't have a goop, man,
好吧，我真的戒酒了，但我偶尔会喝一点，所以也许今晚。也许今晚我要释放猎犬。你要喝一点威士忌和一些牡蛎。听起来你今晚会是一个很长的夜晚。明天可能想睡个懒觉。我需要，而且我知道你没有Goop男士产品，
but I really feel like I need a good face scrub. And I'm not even being coy. I'm being real. I will vouch for that. I'll scrub it. Our face scrub is unisex. Is it? And you should get it.
但我真的觉得我需要一个好的面部磨砂膏。我甚至不是在装模作样。我是认真的。我会为此担保。我会擦洗它。我们的面部磨砂膏是中性的。是吗？你应该买它。
It's called Goop Glow Microjourn. I'll use a woman. I have two older sisters. I used to use their stuff all the time. It's for everybody. It's not overly femininely fragrant. It's for men and women. I'll send you some, Will.
它叫Goop Glow Microjourn。我会用一个女人。我有两个姐姐。我以前一直用她们的东西。它是给每个人的。它没有过于女性化的香味。它是给男人和女人的。我会寄给你一些，威尔。
I'm gonna send you. I'm sending it. I'll get your address from Danny D's and I'll send you up. Yes. Good, yes. I'll send you guys all some Goop. We're gonna hold you to that.
我要寄给你。我正在寄。我会从丹尼D那里得到你的地址，我会寄给你。是的。好，是的。我会寄给你们所有人一些Goop。我们要让你信守诺言。
I can't. I need some. We ordered some food off the Goop site the other night and loved it. Thank you. Loved it. We're excited about that. And so excited that our penises are screaming.
我不能。我需要一些。我们前几天在Goop网站上订了一些食物，很喜欢。谢谢。很喜欢。我们对此很兴奋。而且很兴奋我们的阴茎在尖叫。
Yeah, you gotta yell into the vagina. I know. Lots of vaginas. This is, Will, if you ever need anybody for a sex ed talk, you know Jason's your guide now. I know. I'm here. I'm pretty cheap, too.
是啊，你得对着阴道大喊。我知道。很多阴道。这是，威尔，如果你需要任何人进行性教育谈话，你知道杰森现在是你的向导。我知道。我在这里。我也很便宜。
Where were you, Jason? Where were you? God. Thank you so much for doing this. It's nice of you to join us. You guys are so great. What a fun, when did you start doing this? We don't even know.
你在哪里，杰森？你在哪里？天哪。非常感谢你做这件事。很高兴你能加入我们。你们太棒了。多有趣，你什么时候开始做这个的？我们甚至不知道。
Just at a boredom a year ago. And why? For no reason. We wanted to talk. We have no lives. Okay. Yeah. Honestly.
只是因为一年前的无聊。为什么？没理由。我们想聊天。我们没有生活。好吧。是啊。老实说。
You should do one. Do a Goop chat. Are you gonna say, is there a format? No. No, is there like? You need a Wikipedia and an internet service. You can attest to this, too. You can tell our listener that we don't have any format,
你应该做一个。做一个Goop聊天。你要说，有格式吗？没有。没有，有像？你需要一个维基百科和一个互联网服务。你也可以证明这一点。你可以告诉我们的听众我们没有任何格式，
that we just start rolling. There's no, right? There's no preamble. That's great. That's fine. But I was just wondering, is there like a larger thesis around like? That would require, thank you.
我们只是开始滚动。没有，对吧？没有序言。太棒了。没关系。但我只是在想，有没有像更大的论文围绕像？那需要，谢谢。
The why or what you're trying to. There's no theme. There's no goal. Okay, great. Well, it's really fun. I've been winging it since 1970. Why would I start planning now? Thank you for lending some smarts to us today.
为什么或你试图做什么。没有主题。没有目标。好吧，太棒了。嗯，真的很有趣。我从1970年开始就一直在即兴发挥。我为什么要现在开始计划？谢谢你今天给我们带来了一些智慧。
Oh, please. That's a pleasure. Enjoy the rest of the day. You guys are awesome. Thank you so much. This is so great. What fun. Thank you so much.
哦，拜托。那是我的荣幸。享受这一天的剩余时间。你们太棒了。非常感谢。这太棒了。多有趣。非常感谢。
Thanks, Glenn. Bye, bye, bye. Bye. Bye. She's like a warm, cozy blanket you want on you all the time. Yeah, like a warm, what kind of drink would she be if she would, I guess like a hot chocolate? No, something more comforting and soothing.
谢谢，格伦。再见，再见，再见。再见。再见。她就像一条温暖、舒适的毯子，你一直想盖在身上。是啊，像一条温暖的，如果她会，我想像热巧克力？不，更舒适和舒缓的东西。
Like a broth, like a hot broth. Like a bone broth. Let me just say this, let me just say that I don't mean to be too indelicate because, but I've only met her a handful of times and I have worked with her mom who I adore. And I just thought she was awesome. She was so...
像肉汤，像热肉汤。像骨汤。让我这么说吧，让我这么说，我不想太不客气，因为，但我只见过她几次，我和她妈妈一起工作过，我很崇拜她。我只是觉得她太棒了。她太……
Yeah, that's what I'm saying. When I said in the middle, I was like, you're so chill and down to earth and like together. I know. I got a real crush on her now. Oh, did it start just now? Welcome to the earth.
是啊，这就是我说的。当我在中间说的时候，我说，你太冷静、脚踏实地，而且，在一起。我知道。我现在真的迷上她了。哦，是刚才开始的吗？欢迎来到地球。
Yeah, it did. It did. It just started. I mean, I never realized. And then just talking to her, I've got a, yeah. I think Sean's gonna kick Scotty out today. I think Sean, you've got a crush too. She confuses me.
是啊，确实。确实。刚开始。我是说，我从来没意识到。然后只是和她聊天，我有一个，是啊。我想肖恩今天要把斯科蒂踢出去。我想肖恩，你也迷上了。她让我困惑。
A little bit, right? She confuses me. Wait, Sean, hang on, Sean, were you confused? I was a little confused. I was, you know, found her very attractive and I liked the little black top she had on. Terrific. It's okay to say top, right?
有一点，对吧？她让我困惑。等等，肖恩，等等，肖恩，你困惑了吗？我有点困惑。我，你知道，觉得她很有吸引力，我喜欢她穿的那件黑色小上衣。太棒了。说上衣没关系，对吧？
Yep. With the poofy shoulders? Yeah, the poofy shoulders. Short sleeves. The glasses and the... And the blowout. And the hair. Listener, you missed it.
是的。有蓬松肩膀的那件？是啊，蓬松的肩膀。短袖。眼镜和……还有吹出来的发型。还有头发。听众，你错过了。
But boy, is she not comfortable in her skin? Or what? She's so comfortable. She is so comfortable in her radiant skin. In her well hydrated, glowing... How great does she... And by the way, this is gonna be, people are gonna be like, well, this is misogynistic.
但是天哪，她对自己的皮肤不舒服吗？还是什么？她太舒服了。她太舒服了。她在她容光焕发的皮肤里。在她水分充足、发光的……她看起来多棒……顺便说一下，这会是，人们会说，好吧，这是厌女症。
No, it's not. Any person, any human, I would say, they look great. She looks great. Yeah, she looks fabulous. Exactly. And she's got the brains and everything. It's okay to compliment somebody. On their looks.
不，不是。任何人，任何人类，我会说，他们看起来很棒。她看起来很棒。是啊，她看起来棒极了。确实。而且她有大脑和一切。赞美某人是可以的。
You guys look decent. You know what I mean? Not terrible. I can say that. Not terrible. I think I like it pretty good. Yeah. Yeah.
关于他们的外表。你们看起来不错。你知道我的意思吗？不糟糕。我可以这么说。不糟糕。我想我挺喜欢的。是啊。是啊。
Gosh. You know, I mean, if she didn't flip you, Sean, maybe she at least made you... Bye. Bye. Bye. Yeah, yeah, yeah. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
天哪。你知道，我是说，如果她没有让你翻身，肖恩，也许她至少让你……再见。再见。再见。是啊，是啊，是啊。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。